[Music]
folks it's official we are entering the
age of enlightenment my friend a true
feminist in the best sense of the word
and a fearless defender of free speech
christina hoff sommers was invited to
speak at Lewis and Clark law school this
week here's what happened when she began
her talk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
putting aside the creepiness of the
clone like repetitive chanting from the
protesters their use of free speech
actually isn't a use of free speech at
all while of course they have the right
to protest your right to exercise your
free speech doesn't come at the expense
of someone else's right to exercise
theirs so what this means is yes you can
peacefully protest outside of event you
can silently protest inside of an event
you can hold all the signs you want and
you can encourage others to join your
cause you cannot however use your
freedoms to trample on the freedoms of
others this chanting which again took
place before christina had even begun to
speak reminded me of when i was at UCLA
with my lowly innopolis about two years
ago protesters screamed spit through
garbage cans pulled fire alarms and even
called in bomb threats before we even
took the stage perhaps most egregiously
though was the group of students who
linked arms to create a human wall to
stop us and other viewers from even
going inside the venue itself apparently
they aren't against walls they just
don't like Trump's wall Cristina's talk
continued through the chanting and the
protesters then broke out in song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
quite a catchy tune wouldn't you say
of course christina hoff sommers isn't a
fascist at all she's just an old-school
liberal who dare challenge modern-day
leftism ironically these people so keen
on fighting the fake fascism in their
minds don't understand that they
themselves are the ones who are actually
using fascist tactics of silencing and
drowning out their opponents until there
is no opposition remaining at all but if
you're still confused here's a simple
definition of fascism fascism is a form
of radical authoritarian nationalism
characterized by dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
control of industry and commerce which
came to prominence in early 20th century
Europe do you think that christina hoff
sommers is for dictatorial power is she
for forcible suppression of opposition
to top it off she even works at the
American Enterprise Institute which is
against control of industry and commerce
now just think for a moment if the idea
is that these students were espousing
were the set of ideas in power they
actually would be for dictatorial
control as they believe their cause is
the most just and their opponents are
simply evil how do you think it would be
going for dissent and opposition in
their system perhaps the most insidious
piece of the cultural Marxism that we
see spreading on college campuses these
days is that it is using the freedoms
that our democratic capitalist society
has against itself of course it would
never offer these same protections to
minority voices in the dystopian future
that it would bring while this event
thankfully wasn't nearly as violent as
when Milo went to UC Berkeley and the
school burned down or when it took six
hundred thousand dollars of security to
ensure that Ben Shapiro could speak
there without threat this display at
Lewis and Clark is just another reminder
of how the backwards thinking of
cultural Marxism
is coming for all dissenters cloaked in
the mask of tolerance and diversity
these incidences are happening all over
colleges all over the country and
turning places of higher learning into
places where people are just getting
high on intersectionality sadly this
story really only broke on right-leaning
blogs and was only shared by the usual
suspects who continually defend freedom
of expression as of recording this I
haven't seen any left-leaning websites
that covered it the reason for this of
course is twofold on one hand when you
can win arguments by silencing your
opponents your job is pretty easy but
also and perhaps more importantly the
good actors on the Left which I still
believe there are some who want to call
out events like this rarely do because
they know that the same tactics of
smearing and silencing will eventually
be used against them and then they'll be
purged from their former home just as
former guests of mine like Brett
Weinstein Laura Kipnis Lindsey Shepard
and others who dare speak out against
this tyrannical foe diversity movement
the silver lining though of course is
that the more that people like brat
Laura and others speak out the more room
they give for people like you to do the
exact same in your life speaking of
Berkeley I spoke there yesterday with
Heather McDonald and Steve Simpson and
I'll be speaking at many other colleges
in the coming months come join me
wherever I may be and ask me as many
hard questions in the Q&A as you would
like I ask only one thing which is that
if you sing please make it a little
snappier than what we just heard a cover
of journey Fleetwood Mac or even Frank
Sinatra would be preferable
[Music]
joining me today is the senior editor of
the Atlantic a contributor on MSNBC and
the author of the new book Trump
accuracy the corruption of the american
republic david frum welcome to the rubin
report thank you so much for having me
I'm glad to have you here I've wanted
you on for a couple years I think at
this point you were a tough guy to track
down but we made it happen
I'm findable yeah I'm not in hiding yet
you're not in hiding yet you could be
maybe by the end of this interview
because I let my guests talk and you
never know right
that's the Twitter formula that you're
you're like 140 characters away from
career self-immolation yeah well we've
got about 60 minutes we'll see you about
immolation immediately all right so a
lot of things I want to talk to you
about I thought your your personal
history is interesting and usually when
I see you on television you're talking
about the the day-to-day machinations of
politics you are Canadian I did not know
that I find that I like Canadians yet
everyone does why are you people so
agreeable because they're so
passive-aggressive I grew I grew up in
Toronto I'm just we have place in Prince
Edward County which is what to a nap
East out of Toronto to an hours east of
Toronto where my wife and I and our
children are spent summers now for
almost three decades Canada is a you
know is a kind of mirror image of the
United States with some things omitted
some things intensified and so I think
it offers Americans often a kind of well
what if examination of what the United
States might have been under different
circumstances yes that's an interesting
phrase what do you think so mitad and
what do you think's intensified well so
Canada didn't have the American South
didn't have slavery didn't have a Civil
War Canada had a peaceful separation
from Great Britain so it doesn't have
the mill it doesn't have the kind of
citizen military traditions Canadians a
very different attitude toward guns I
mean they're my neighbors in Prince
Edward County all have are not all but
many have long guns hunting pieces
shotguns but the idea of having a
handgun or a military style weapon is a
very alien idea for Canadians yeah do
you think some of the Canadian attitude
is also that just there's a lot of
geographic space and not that many
people actually yes well there it can be
kind of it can be kind of spooky tonight
I mean they're they're great city so
Canadian Canada's much more urbanized
place in the United States
Canadians are more likely to live in
Toronto Vancouver Calgary Edmonton
Montreal those places but and there
there's a I'm in a line from a poem the
wild is always there and even when you
live in the center of Toronto you can
head off you can start driving and
pretty soon you you're in the wild yeah
interesting so your mom was on the
Canadian Broadcasting YES Network or
company CBC coming in broadcasting
corporation corporation okay Linda from
tell me a little bit that was my Linda
promise my sister who's a member of the
Canadian icing on a few things are they
different no no but she's a very
prominent person to Linda from as a
member of the Canadian Senate a leader
in the Canadian Conservative Party my
late mother Barbara from was the host I
had correct here my biography Keaney
arresting you enter of Agra she was a
radio interview on a show called as it
happens for a decade and then was the
founder of a show called journal which
was one of those face to face TV shows
at a time when satellite instant
satellite communication was quite new
she died in 1992 at the age of 54 was
your family always political I mean it
sounds like probably right well but my
family was interested in politics
my late father was a businessman not a
not involved in the political world and
he had a lot of distance from from
politics but yes I mean my parents
dinner table was a place it was a
high-pressure environment and they they
thought deeply about things but they
were not ideological and one of the one
of the places where I really I mean
learned to think was around that dinner
table because you know my my mother's
very skeptical about everything
including her own children and the way
she when you were saying something she
didn't like but she would never argue
with you which you just set marching
these two lines of interrogatory
questions and you would eventually
realize I'm caught between these two
lines and she would force you to think
more deeply about and not just political
things but about everything why do you
do that why do you say that why do you
think that's funny
and it made you a more conscious person
and I try to live up to that in the way
I raise my own children you never try I
try never to tell them what to do or
what they what to think but instead to
challenge them to think and to think
more deeply and not just about the big
things but about everything do you think
that's what we're fundamentally missing
in society right now I mean I think it's
what I try to bring to this show I try
to let my guests talk even when I
disagree with them and maybe poke and
prod them in ways to to learn a little
bit more but that everyone in the media
these days is just pounding at each
other and hitting each other and trying
to destroy each other instead of sort of
going along that journey with you and
figuring out why you think that way and
yeah and more importantly how you think
I I think it's just human nature I think
I think it's human nature to be tough on
others and soft on ourselves and it it's
a real discipline and to say you know
what maybe I should be soft on others
and tough on myself so there's an
interesting story I want to get this
totally right when you were 14 you
volunteered for the Ontario New
Democratic Party yes so far so good
so far so good and for those who don't
follow Canadian politics as closely so
the Ontario NDP is the Left Party in
Canada it's a multi-party system and can
of course has a parliamentary system and
there was a provincial election and I
was interested in seeing how politics
worked I wasn't I didn't really have
political ideas but I was interested in
campaigns and I volunteered on that back
campaign so on that campaign you're 14
years old and on your commute you're
reading The Gulag Archipelago well it
was a bus subway streetcar to go it was
really something for volunteer right it
was summer holiday and so my mother had
given me as a birthday present the
paperback edition of The Gulag
Archipelago and urged me to read it
and so I had a lot of time on that
commute and had it hit me like a bomb
and I think I mean my family you know
are we're not my parents got I would
have Europe my family my families got
out of Europe before the war but they
left people behind it's Poland but most
of my father
family were annihilated in the Holocaust
and very whereas there was something he
was always very conscious in my mind and
then here was this other story that I
had not heard so much about and it it
saved me how does that shape a 14 year
old well it it what it makes you aware
of is that human history is very tragic
that you can't wrote a lot that power
can be abused and it makes you begin to
think very hard but well how do we build
a society and so there I was on the
Toronto subway system in a society that
really worked and it forces you to think
most societies aren't like this in most
societies people are exposed to random
terror and and to dictatorial power how
do you make societies that that work and
the protect people and respect human
dignity and human freedom
so I began and of course at 14 you have
no answers but you become interested in
the question and what you also know is
that when people say I have a great
scheme for Humanity it just requires a
few prison camps way you learn you know
what it's probably not such a good
scheme right although they usually don't
tell you it requires prison gifts it
usually tells you requires a lot of good
things right I mean isn't that the the
real trick but it's currently but it
tells you that at you there are warnings
early on they're warnings early on in
any utopian project like that we're
going to have to you know break break
some eggs here to make no an omelet and
at first you're right at first the eggs
are not at first the eggs are kind of
small but the first unit you can tell
those steps and that one of the things
that you know I mean this is I think one
of the reasons why people look at what's
happening on campuses with such alarm
because you know obviously those are the
people who are shouting down people on
campus they don't have police forces but
they've made it pretty clear how if they
ever did have a police for exactly how
they'd use yeah so when I first came
across you I think it was probably maybe
ten years ago you were on real time a
lot and I would say I would just see you
on different televisions and it was
probably when for me personally I was a
little more left than maybe I am at the
moment
or at least the whole Overton Window has
just shifted that it's hard to put
anyone on the traditional map anymore
but I always sort of you always struck
me as like a sensible conservative I
never watched you and was like ah that's
the guy I disagree with on the right you
know in some like crazed way what what
does conservatism because you you are a
conservative right I would say I would
use the adjective I am conservative my
I've stopped using the noun a
conservative interesting that's an
interesting distinction and it makes
sense to me relative to so many things
changing right now what does
conservatism generally mean to you well
I think it starts with the way our
brains are built that there are people
who are more conscious of risk and
they're people were less conscious of
risk the people who hanker for change
they're people who are ready to stick
with present evils rather than try new
ones and that's just a matter of brain
chemistry then when people with those
different brain chemistry's approach the
problems with society they start
building systems of ideas so the reason
I stopped using the phrase ain't
conservative and stop talking about the
conservative movement is what I would
have called conservatism when I came out
of college in 1982 was a set of answers
to the problems in the 1970s and 80s
inflation crime the Soviet menace the
disorder in American life a sluggish
productivity growth and the
conservatives of those days had a series
of policy recommendations for those
problems and by and large they weren't
and the result was that the problems
either were overcome or anyway so
reduced in significance they stopped
being the most important problems in
Americans carotenoid new problems came
to the fore and about those new problems
conservatives had the same old answers
they've had back in 1982 and it became a
kinda fetish that if lower taxes were
the right way to respond to low
productivity growth in 1982 then if you
had completely different problems in
2008 and obviously still lower taxes
must be the same must work just as well
as they did with a completely different
set of problems in 1982 so I think what
is what has happened is that the concern
movement conservative politics he's a
fossil it's it's it's interesting in
that reveal it's like unearthing some
piece of rock from a different
geological era it tells you something
about what people had on their minds in
1982 but if you say how am I going to
solve the problems of 2018 not so
helpful yeah so when people say that
they're conservatives now does that have
any particular meaning to you like I
guess there is the set that you're
talking about from the 82 that's going
you know what you know what the answers
are then but that seems very different
from now and then of course we're
obviously going to spend a lot of time
talking about Trump and that really is
flipped as well well this is what is
made from possible this is why the
conservative movement has sort of worked
itself out of a job so the actual
content of conservatism as you know what
does conservatism have to say about the
opioid epidemic what does it have to say
about the Great Recession what does it
have to say but the collapse in life
expectancy among non-college Americans
what does it have to say about America's
place in the world you know in a world
in which we're no longer competing with
an ideological nuclear superpower of the
Soviet Union but with a with these
opportunistic actors that like Russia
and China as conservatism has become
more useless to help those problems what
what it has been left behind is an
attitude what conservatism I think means
to most people say I'm a conservative
it means anti leftism find out what the
what the American Left is talking about
at any given moment and not only think
the opposite of it but actually make
your opposition to that that group of
people the organizing principle of your
politics your sort of defining principle
basically your defining principle now
what that does is first it makes it does
a couple things first it makes
opposition ISM it means you're always
against never for and the second thing
it means is you never have the
initiative because you don't know what
you think about anything until somebody
else tells you first and I think that's
one of the reasons why conservatives
were so vulnerable to Trump is that you
had an intellectual estate that was
largely untended and falling into
disrepair and Donald Trump came and
kicked the
and moved in were there any candidates
that you liked out of that crew before
Trump came in and wrecked the whole
thing look there been a lot of I have
almost always supported well until 2016
I always supported the Republican
nominee for president and I thought
there have been a lot of people who have
had real promise to make a good
precedent Mitt Romney would have made a
very very good president conservatism
problem a Republican isms problem has
been that you take people who are have
real promise as leaders and you then
connect them to a program that can't win
a democratic election you know since the
end of the Cold War conservatives won
the Republican nominee for president has
won a majority of the popular vote
exactly once that was in 2004 in the
aftermath of 9/11 it's no longer there's
no longer a national majority for what
Republicans are offering and what has
happened and it's no surprise because
one year said well our big idea is to
take the Medicare guarantee away from
everybody under 55 to put Medicaid on
the path toward extinction and to use
all of that to finance more tax cuts
like those that worked in the 1980s in a
completely different set of
circumstances that you're not talking to
or about me so good people have been
committed to an unworkable program and
what has happened then has been that as
Republicans have lost the parties become
more desperate and we're vulnerable but
when it's also happened is that you have
had a an increasingly self-conscious
move in the conservative world and this
is part of the Trump Hawk receipt when I
talk about in the book to say well if we
can't win a majority of the people what
we are going to we're going to cope with
that by redefining who the proper people
are we're going to define the country
we're going to shrink our definition of
who are the people and divide the
country between the people and those
people and the people that's all we care
about and we're going to try to find
ways to prevent those people from
participating in even voting so there's
a couple things there so it's
interesting you mentioned taxes a couple
of times generally speaking when I have
conservative sit across from you there
for tax cuts no matter what and that's
what you're saying that there was the 82
crew basically that was fort and then
this fossil remained and people are
always for now but it's it's rare to sit
across from a conservative and you're
basically saying that there are
instances at least where the tax cuts
are not a problem yeah but what one of
the really damaging things I mean
societies have states states need
revenue so there are their thing there
are ways you know the United Sates might
not need so much tax money if for
example it didn't spend twice it twice
as much per person on health care as
everybody else in the world I mean you
look at the actual dollars the United
States spends on on health provision for
terrible results it's very expensive
conservatives by and large are not
interested in getting their fingers into
that problem they're not so the
government needs revenue and it has to
be funded and part of the fossilization
happens it's conservative say you say
we've got a problem whatever it is and
considered well if I can solve it with a
tax cut then I'm for doing something if
I can only solve it by having a spending
increase that I won't do anything
well then happens it's cynical operators
say well what if we take our spending
increase instead of doing it through an
appropriation we do it through a tax
credit how do you feel that oh then I'm
fine right and the result is that
whether the problem is housing or higher
education or caring for disabled
children that conservatives can be sold
a solution in the form of a tax credit
which is usually the least efficient way
of solving up a problem and the result
is we that you get this kind of
malformed state where the United States
has a really big and expensive
government but it's financed in
especially inefficient ways and it
addresses problems and especially in
efficient ways so is the first part
there though that nobody actually cut
spending you know I've had been Shapiro
in here a bunch of times and that's what
he talks about that
you keep raising taxes forever and ever
and ever but that really we have this
just giant monstrosity of a government
that's incredibly inefficient I mean
even health care aside just everything
all the mid-level bureaus and regulators
and just this massive federal government
that was never supposed to get so big
that we never actually really look at
how much of that we could chop away at
where then if we did a little of that we
could have the the sort of relevant
conversations about tax cuts that you're
talking about well that's partly true
and partly not the United States what
does the Unites States government spend
its money on defense Medicare Medicaid
Social Security
I think that's those things together I
think that's about 80 percent so the
rest of the government you know is I
mean I think it's true that dollar for
dollar the US government is less
efficient than that of other countries
mostly because of the inheritance of not
having a proper civil service that the
idea that president starts off by
appointing the top 10,000 jobs in the
civil service it's highly political you
get a lot of people who shouldn't
basically have no background of
government don't know what they're doing
and things are not done in a very
efficient way also the power of Congress
means there are a lot of people who are
always trying to you know put in some
special benefit and things happen that
don't make so you have military bases
and places where they shouldn't be but
if you were this is this is why I say
conservatives about is obsolete if you
want to reduce the state's share of
expen and really I mean not just by
repackaging things as tax that are right
you know that I mean one of the ways we
for example fund the care of disabled
children is through a series of tax
credits that are not labeled as
expenditures but really are you have to
do something about Medicare and Medicaid
and so the conservative the idea has
been okay well the answer is we're going
to take away Medicare and Medicaid from
people and the reason that the Obama
period has been such a crisis and the
period afterwards is the defeat over the
defeat of the conservative attempt to
the repeal the Affordable Care Act and
to pass the Ryan plan means the
Conservatives have to now face a world
in which the United States has joined
the other developed countries and having
something like or something closer to a
universal health care guarantee the old
idea will save money just by not
covering people that is not going to be
workable in the politics of the 21st
century so that means you have to
actually pay attention to how Medicare
works and you have said how while
covering everybody do we squeeze costs
out of the system and that requires a
commitment to policy detail the
conservatives don't like to do as they
like the sweeping comment we just need
to cut all this waste but the when you
say well where is the wasted Medicare
well the answer is with the United
States over pays for all of these
services per unit and doctors make more
money in the United States than they do
in other places you have you have these
but you also have this problem if you
have a sick or population then up people
do in other countries Americans die
earlier they're less likely to our
seatbelts they have more gun accidents
you have to delve to deal with this
problem you have to delve into detail in
a way that the conservative preference
for ideology over factual specificity
makes conservatives not very useful at
is anyone good at that these days though
really like really saying you know we
had look if you look at the real grass
root movement on both sides I mean
Bernie was pretty extreme left and Trump
was whatever it's hard to call extreme
right but we'll get into that whatever
you call that that you know just the
wrecking of the system so you have two
competing forces look we have a lot of
political messianism that's a really
important point but here here let me put
instead of looking at what at the two
sides of if you were to take the
thousand people in the United States who
know most about Medicare and Medicaid or
the hundred who know most about Medicare
and Medicaid I'm guessing 90 of the
hundred and nine 990 of the thousand
maybe not nine hundred thousand would be
people of the center-left
because conservatives just don't care
about that kind of knowledge and so
they're always at a disadvantage that
they don't care they just don't think
the government should be involved in
this like that the fundamental bloke at
worst well okay yeah it's not the job of
the government really but they know so
every once in a while somebody will put
his head above the parapet and say I
don't think the government shouldn't be
providing health care for everybody
right you lose an election that that is
how Donald Trump became the Republican
nominee that's what Paul Ryan does not
think the government should provide
health care to everybody mm-hmm the
problem is the Republican primary voter
thinks the gut well the government
shouldn't provide health care to
everybody but they should provide health
care to everyone like me so yes they
should provide health care to all the
over 65s they should provide health care
to all the veterans but you're once you
do that you're into a very big program
and once you're saying government should
provide health care to all the over 65s
that's where most of the spending takes
place yeah anyway so just to be clear
you have a ideological difference with
maybe the Paul Ryan approach but you
think it's a legitimate way of looking
at the government right it's certainly
understand it's a way to think yeah for
sure you can argue that point but it's
not a way that a political party wants
to compete for power in the United
States can think because the voters
won't accept it so what ends up
happening is that the Republicans have a
bunch of commitment they have a crunch
of theoretical commitments and a bunch
of operational commitments and those
they don't line up and in fact the
Republican Party does maintain Medicare
it does maintain Medicaid and it tries
to find little economies usually in not
very efficient ways but the result is
because it doesn't care about how those
problems work and it's not psychically
committed to them there is no one there
saying we're going to cut we're going to
how is it that Germany and France and
Switzerland the Netherlands Canada cover
more people have longer life
expectancies and spend less you know
they're not the difference between what
the United States spends the difference
of the Americans spending the American
economy in health care and that of the
other developed countries is about three
three or four points of GDP we
is bigger than the defense budget mm-hmm
so what does that say then just about we
don't even have to make this about
conservatives per se what does that say
about our system if a guy came up let's
say the Republican nominee came up and
really was talking about that the ins
and outs I mean no matter what let's
just look at 2016 I mean he would have
been clubbed over the head by trauma and
this no don't remember
trub campaign sorry Trump said Trump is
a was a great discount this is what I
mean by the hollowness so Trump said I'm
going to protect Medicare I'm going to
protect Medicaid Trump campaigned as the
guy who's going to who was the first
Republican who really made his peace
with the American social insurance
system when conservatives said Trump
wasn't a conservative they were right
and that's why he beat them inside their
own party Trump begins by beating the
Republican of world he bins begins by
defeating Fox News and bending all of
them to his will now he had no idea what
he was talking about he had no plan for
executing any of this but he do you
think that's really true because I hear
this with a lot of people that he had
either no idea what he was doing yeah no
no plan or anything
someone has are no idea yeah and reveals
that every day he doesn't know he
doesn't understand any but what does
that tell you about all of us yeah
that's true like is that saying one of
the interviewers had said during the mr.
Trump you say you're going to preserve
Medicare and Medicaid what does Medicare
do and what does medical do and what's
the difference I will bet you the amount
of money the Republican Party are going
to corruptly put in his pockets of
mar-a-lago that he couldn't have
answered that question yeah so that I
completely agree with I did a video
before the election saying if you want
to stump Trump asked him what the three
branches of government are and what
they're supposed to do he was asked what
the three elements of the nuclear triad
are and didn't know that so that kind of
stuff I do agree but this thing about
sort of there was no plan or is no plan
I you know some way even if even if I
can intellectually get there with you
there's something about that idea that
then he duped by I mean it's scary I
guess I would say it's pretty scary to
think that someone who had no plan duped
the rest of us like that
that inherently seems like a plan at
some
I'm started talking about plans at
different levels Donald Trump is one of
the great scam artists of all time he
scammed the people Trump University he
and the scam was possible because of the
disillusionment of so many people with
responsible politics but what what he
intuited I mean I mean he's not that he
Dom Trump has certain talents and
geniuses I'm he is a genius at finding
the weakness in things and he understood
the weakness in the institutional
Republican Party which is that they were
offering a message that their own voters
hate it and I have a lot of detail on
that in the book about how when you
actually showed Republican voters
Republican primary voters what Paul Ryan
wanted to do they spoiled from it mm-hmm
but he's gonna take away my Medicare
he's gonna take away my mother's nursing
home that's the plan that's the famous
Ryan plan so Donald Trump understood
that that and what he then understood as
well was that in the absence of a
program that this aunt he left is some
that had become what conservatism was
this was a series of resentments and
rages that were waiting for somebody who
had articulated who who raged and
resented as powerfully as they did I
mean Republicans the previous Republican
nominees would sometimes tap these
feelings try to channel them but they
didn't share them Donald Trump seriously
okay so before we go fully into Trump
and then we're gonna spend the rest of
the interview on Trump I just wanna talk
a little bit about the modern Democrats
and and the left in general and all that
so what do you make of the the feeling
that he was going for I think that's a
pretty legit feeling on what's happened
with the Left related to free speech and
the endless hysteria and everyone's a
bigot a racist and identity politics all
of that that feeling I think is legit do
you see that as a legit feeling look in
our group Authority that feelings are
legitimate the question is are not even
feeling I see it as a legit reality
looking that he was talking about
there's a little collegiate reality I
also think what what behind behind all
of those
things you described he's a new fact in
the politics the United States in the
past 15 20 years which is that we are
moving into a period of intensifying
ethnic competition for power for money
and for the right to say that that what
to talk about to define what it means to
be an American and the countries made
this big gamble on changing itself and
across the developed world countries
like the United Sates have made similar
Gamble's the proportion of the
foreign-born in Sweden is now as high as
in the United States the proportion of
foreign-born in Germany's nearly as high
as in the United States that are having
massive problems there are immigration
is all is a source of massive social
tension and we know a lot of the
immigration happened without anybody
ever consciously intending it and
without much of a debate over it and
with a refusal to tally costs and
benefits in an accurate way so these
countries have been changed and what you
have is then a series of new demands and
new resentments and that's one of the
one of the reasons that the conservatism
I grew up with the cell out of date is
look back in 1985 the argument between
liberals and conservatives was basically
an argument about the economy that and
this is true not just in every developed
country we'd have you had a party of the
people who worked for wages and the
party of the people who owned capital
assets and workforce hours the left were
the people who whose jobs are supported
by taxes the right where the people's
jobs are supported by profits if you're
in management you were on the right if
you were on a union you were on the left
not to sound Marxist about this but
essentially your relationship to the
means of production was the was the the
organizing principle of politics what
also happened in 1985 was it people
remembered that this kind of politics
could spiral out of control and they'd
seen it happen in the 1930s and and you
could get fascist movements you can get
communist movements and so there were
attempts to temper the competition
between the wage people and the salary
people between the owners and the
workers that's and so you had that you
had kind of a accountant the left except
at a market economy
the right accepted a social insurance
state but that's what the argument was
about and that's what we've run on now
for that and there's a plan some time
but that has ceased with the collapse of
socialist that argument ended the the
modern left is not really a socialist
movement anymore there I mean they
people will sometimes use the word
they'll have but I mean back in nineteen
fifty there are people who really
thought that if the government owned the
banks the banks would make better
lending decisions than they did then
they would if they're privately no one
thinks that now I mean I don't really
you don't think that there's plenty of
people on the Left I think that it's
just if so we'll just sort of
incrementally get there they had three
hundred and thirty million people you
know somebody who thinks I mean no no I
don't mean no one but I mean that if
that if Bernie was president that
eventually do I think the creeping
movement of this yeah Elizabeth Warren
that do they want to movement I think
Elizabeth Warren does not want the
government on the banks no I don't think
she I believe that Elizabeth Warren does
not think government should own the
steel companies she doesn't believe that
government should own the commanding
heights of Industry I'm sure she does
not bladder I don't know about owning it
but what about just controlling it to
the point where in effect its ownership
I know I know you I know I don't have
she does exist okona I don't think she
thinks they should manage it she
believes in a social market economy I
mean if you were to say to her what is
the best run country on earth
she breeding always used to say Denmark
was the best one country Denmark is a
free-market society it's got a bigger
social insurance system in the United
States and he said that because the
reason he said that was he was never a
serious answer abyss he didn't he'd stop
caring but that's not what politics is
about what politics is about is in 1985
if I knew how you made your living i
could probably guess how you voted today
if I know where your grandparents come
from I know how you vote so if your
grandparents did not belong to the local
ethnic majority whether in the United
States or Germany or Britain you are in
the party what you used to be the left
if your grandparents do belong did do or
did belong to the local ethnic majority
you are and what is the power party of
the right used to me and that's true
however you make your living however
much a little money you have and that
was not true in former days so you have
this politics of ethnic competition and
that's why politics as one reason why
politics are so much more virulent
because
you know in the end you with money you
can always split the difference
somewhere we say will you take 20% no
will you take 23% what Oh
28% okay we have a deal right but when
you're competing what does it mean to be
an American
we haven't who gets to define American
miss we haven't found a way to split the
difference on that and until we do we're
gonna have very very limp politics I
mean there's this you know when when the
Sarah Palin's and others talk about what
it means to be a real American some
things are real American other things
are not they're looking for a way to
claim ethnic legitimation that we get
you know we may not have the numbers
anymore but we still define the country
and that is one of the things that's
going on as what these political
correctness battles are all about I mean
it's always true that there are things
people don't say no only things that
people don't say it even if they're free
to sit there things they don't say how
does that happen
that those there are things that you
don't say and who gets to decide and
that's what we're struggling over the
people what we are calling political
correctness is people think there used
to be a set of rules above of taboos we
have a new set of taboos we want the old
taboos to be unta boo and we want to
impose the new taboo and the people on
the receiving end of that say we like
our old taboos and we don't want these
new taboos and that that's where Donald
Trump is is coming from I mean if that's
a real dispute it's important but it's
it's new and it's dangerous and we don't
know how to manage it and we have this
deeply opportunistic actor whose are
taking advantage of it okay so before we
fully dive into that then what it does
this show you that our brand of
multiculturalism which has worked better
than virtually any state you know
European state are our melting pot does
this tell you that the experiment is
starting to fail I mean is this the the
litmus test for that well you know
because that's what it sounds like
first the American melting pot never
worked as well as Americans told
themselves it did unless it's has had a
lot of civic conflict in its history and
not just the civil war and then later
19th century
most violent labor relations anywhere on
earth and those are often about
ethnicity that the the strikers would be
from one group and the police police who
shot them would be from a different
group and the strikes would be broken by
strike breakers who are from a third
group yet again but multiculturalism is
difficult to do and it's especially
difficult to do when you have moved out
of the age of mass production and one
thing when you're bringing in you needed
a lot of bodies to run a modern economy
you don't need so many bodies today and
and we also live in a world in which
whereas before there were a lot of
pretty average-sized rewards today we
live in a world in which they're
gigantic our wants and not such great
rewards and the average what what the
average person gets is not as attractive
relatively speaking as it was two
generations ago all right let's do it
let's dive into this Trump guy because I
sense that everything we've talked about
for the first half year a lot of your
answers now are sort of directly related
to this guy but saw the weakness but not
to the personality of this guy but to
the whole system look here let me I'll
take one last that have to do it on a
wider lens then well yeah you know I
imagine somebody standing on a time line
and the center the time line is 1990 and
they go forward 25 years 2015 and maybe
they go to sleep and they wake up who
are the most important politicians of
the country when they go to sleep Bush
and Clinton who are the most important
politician in the country in 2015 Bush
and Clinton what are they talking about
Iraq and health care you go back 25
years from 1990 here in 1965 and it's a
different world there's an afl-cio there
are riots in the cities there are
liberal Republicans and segregationist
Democrats so we have had this frozen
politics for a long time and it was
ready to be changed and Donald Trump the
existing Republican Party couldn't cope
with it and Donald Trump did he smashed
the system open so he's created some
opportunities for a new kind of
political arranged arrangement because
the old one had become so stale but what
he's also done and this is the theme of
the book
is he's raising questions not just about
the way we do politics but on the whole
political system because he is a deeply
authoritarian personality his project is
authoritarian and the way he governs is
not compatible with a rule of law
society it was gonna happen one way or
another right do you think that's fair
to say or is he so unique or that
personality trait or that you know the
type of person that would be willing to
do it is so unique that he's not we have
like Trump like figures all over the
Western world you know we have a global
crisis well I mean unique to our
American system because there was no one
even though Bernie was actually talking
about rattling the system the same way
and I think that's why there was some
crossover with their audiences we have
people in I mean there's gear builders
there's marine lepen there's the
alternative for Germany we just were
recording just a few days before people
see this program there's an election in
Italy in which the traditional parties
were swept aside and kind of joke party
the five star movement which was founded
by a comedian and which is you know kind
of an authoritarian populist party of
the left is now in league with a kind of
neo fascist party and we are seeing the
breakdown of the traditional parties of
the center driven by slow growth and
ethnic competition well that's what I'm
saying was it gonna happen no matter
what even if Trump had lost this
election or never rose no nothing is
going to happen no matter what people
make choices you know at the darkest
moments in American history in 1932 1860
political parties and political
movements converged on programs that
were constitutional that were liberal in
the broadest sense of the term and they
found leaders who wanted to uphold the
American tradition and change it enough
that it could continue but without
violating its essence this time it's as
if Huey Long had become President 1932
not Franklin Delano Roosevelt okay so
let's just do like a couple minutes of
Russia so that we can get to that
because that we can't talk about Trump
without talking about Russia you you
tweet a lot about Russia I'm right about
right I'll you talk about a lot do you
absolutely believe that
he himself orchestrated or coordinated
some of this stuff with the Russian
government there remain many secrets in
the Russia story but there's no mystery
the exact modalities of how the exchange
happened that remain uncertain but here
here here isn't what I think I do know
and I think what you know we know that
Russia wanted Donald Trump to be
President and even more badly wanted
Hillary Clinton not to be President we
know that they intervened in an in a
massive way and in an industrial scale
and we're learning more and more all the
time how big was to hurt Hillary Clinton
first the Democratic primaries to help
Donald Trump first in the Republican
primaries and then in the general
election to help Trump it Clinton's
expenses can you give me just for people
that are playing total catch-up here so
what are the examples of that well I
mean here's the most dramatic example
the the WikiLeaks tropes are dumped in
weighs exactly timed to help Donald
Trump the Trump people were expecting
the last WikiLeaks dump of the elections
sometime in the first week of October
they knew was coming they'd expected at
dawn about October 4th or 5th it didn't
come that day instead it was dumped on
October 7th within an hour of the access
hollywood tape being broken by david
Farenthold of The Washington Post the
rut the Russians or whoever controls
WikiLeaks which I believe is pretty I
believe and might compel the head of the
CIA believes it's weak leaks is a cutout
for the Russians if not directly
controlled by them they time their last
WikiLeaks dump to help Donald Trump
should he have a crisis in the election
and and it did and it and I in the book
I said give the minute-by-minute
tick-tock where you see it's it's you
know the Russians were there to help
what is the real question whether the
campaign itself was coordinating that or
look we do all sorts of things with
other with foreign governments and
elections and all kind of stuff so
whether whether the campaign actually
was coordinating it with a foreign
government which obviously would donkey
illegal we know that Donald as opposed
to them just doing it and it having to
work out for Trump to hack an Americans
email is a crime it's a big crime if you
know that a crime has been committed
against America
by you by a foreign government you would
be annoyed about that especially if you
expire to be pressing the United States
the idea that Donald so we don't know to
what degree yet we don't know to what
degree if any people on his campaign
work in regular back-and-forth
communication with the Russians but he
stood on a stage and in June of 2016 and
welcomed the Russians breaking American
law to steal his opponents email to his
advantage his son took a meeting with
people who were offering him Russian
hacked information on Hillary Clinton
they didn't at the meeting the Russians
didn't deliver but you know when we say
the Russians we have to clarify between
the government and just other habits
right because everyone says the Russians
as if the lawyer one monolithic thing
the true the lawyer who was at the
meeting was somebody with intense
Kremlin connections and who advertised
that she had Kremlin connections that
she said in them in the famous email to
Don junior the Russian government wants
to elect your father I have information
from the Russian government it could
help your campaign and he said great I
love it especially in the summer I am
telling you that if an emissary from the
Russian government had approached George
W Bush in the election of 2000 and said
I have information in Al Gore they will
help you there wouldn't have been a
meeting there were no phone call to the
FBI and and there might even a been a
phone call to the gore campaign you guys
should know about this what do you think
all right so all right so you believe
that without question there was
coordination oh so I believe the
Russians helped and I believe that
Donald Trump what it's not a belief it's
on video you can look it up no I'm from
welcome to help was ready to accept the
help and profit it from the help and
that and that and I believe it made a
difference in the election I believe
also that there were Russian attempts as
far as we know they're not successful to
interfere with the actual mechanics of
voting in a number of states what here's
what I don't know I don't know whether
information regular information flowed
back from the United States to Russia
after Don juniors meeting I don't know
that I don't know whether the Russian
operation to influence the American
election benefited from any
kind of information provided by American
counterparts those are things we don't
know what what I do know is that Donald
Trump did not act patriotically and he
did not act with respect to the American
political system and I will never get
past that do you think the Democrats
have any of the the same dirt on their
hands no nothing I mean look it's not
beanbag lated many they did many things
I mean when when Hillary Clinton found
that South American beauty queen who was
offended by Donald Trump do i is it
possible the Clinton campaign paid her
money for her story that's what that's
possible but there's a difference
between there by really is a bright line
difference between the usual operations
of American politics which can be pretty
rough and accepting help from the client
the clandestine service of a foreign
government Wayne give you another
example did make a difference so in 2004
it was no secret that Gerhard schröder
Germany and Jacques Chirac the president
France would dearly love to see John
Kerry beat george w bush they made that
very clear
they gave interviews they very clear
they are just counting the minutes right
until Bush was gone and it was also
clear in 2012 that Benjamin Netanyahu of
Israel preferred net Romney to Obama
your allies have opinions it is ready
none of those elections did we have
hostile foreign States China Russia Iran
actors like that working not through
talking to journalists but through
clandestine intelligence services to
help one candidate and hurt another and
have it all be visible and have the
candidate who has helped accept the help
and imagine if Iran had tried to
intervene in 2012 against or for Obama
or Romney and one of those candidates
had said you know Iran if you're
listening thank you for the help right
inconceivable but that's what Trump did
he did it on video it's not a mystery
so right so I want to really talk about
the presidency and sort of the decisions
in that but to sort of get us to some
sort of ending
this if this all unfurls you no way I
think you suspect it will unfurl I mean
as you definitely would be for
impeachment right this is where it's
going so what I'm part of the part that
I'm struggling with this is if we take
all of the people that talk about all
this it seems to me what we're talking
about is okay well you you impeach Trump
and then really then we have to do
something which is unprecedented which
is most likely Pence knew something and
now you have to take the whole
administration out now we suddenly have
Paul Ryan as the president or we have a
redo of the election and then we're
really at war sure just how Trump has
already changed us
so no prep Heat the Russia part of this
is just one of the things that have that
happened in no precedence is Lyndon
Johnson has operated a business while
president no no president in my memory
has directed his party's funds into his
own personal about 80% of the money that
the Republican Party has spent on events
in last year went was paid at a Donald
Trump branded resort so this is like
when they're holding meetings at more La
Gordon a friend of mine sent me this
clip George Shultz was Secretary of
State under Ronald Reagan had been an
important executive maybe CEO at Bechtel
the giant engineering firm and that his
confirmation hearing he was asked mr.
Schultz after you become Secretary of
State well your relationship be with
Bechtel and he said well there's only
one possible answer nothing that's right
that was the standard so what you have
is an attack on every ethical norm of
the US government both financial and
national security and the and half of
the country is being borne along then
the discussions we are having our
discussions that I prompt if in 9 2013
as recently as that I said someday we'll
be having these discussions people think
well we will be so far gone even to
contemplate so that is unprocess about
are we heading toward an impatient of
crisis here's what we're the crisis
we're heading toward and here's what I
really wanted my deepest worries I think
where there's a good chance we're gonna
arrive at this place that Muller is
going to report if he's assumed he's not
fired and he's going to discover a lot
of things that are violations of the law
done by mid-level and even upper level
people and he may discover some you know
financial malpractice is there a lot of
laws about things like declaring near a
foreign agent that there are technical
rules about can't campaign finance and
he will discover or may infractions of
those but the core thing in the Russian
matter that people like me are concerned
about is probably not illegal it's
probably not illegal for an American
politician to work with a hostile
warrant no there isn't such a law and
it's hard to imagine what such a law
would look like and so where we maybe a
year and a half from now is confronting
this that Donald Trump worked in some
way we may be I'm not predicting this
I'm just hypothesizing worked in some
way with a hostile foreign intelligence
service that he himself broke no law in
doing that and now the country is going
to have to process how to deal with that
and it's going to be part of what is
going on in this new era which is
ripping apart the but the the cords that
bind us because one of the things that
makes a country is the assumption how
your connections to your fellow
Americans however much you may disagree
with them and however you may he may
have a different color skin or have a
different accent from you that bond is
more powerful than the bonds outside the
border and as American politics becomes
emphasized I think a lot of people are
saying my connections with this global
movement of reactionary populist forces
are more powerful than my bonds to
fellow Americans of different skin and
different accent and because of that
unless you could show me that Donald
Trump literally broke a federal criminal
statute I don't mind what he did so how
do we get out of this how do we get out
of either that inevitability or do do we
just that end up literally fighting on
the streets the way we get out of it is
we have to the new American nation hood
and so we have to do that if we get out
of this we're gonna do something some
are going to sound pretty liberal and
some are gonna sound pretty conservative
I believe we need a lot less immigration
because that's you have to we have to
make a nation
again we've taken on a lot of new people
hey and I'm a naturalized citizen myself
I grew up in Canada my family's from
Eastern Europe making nations is hard
and time-consuming so that's the
conservative part of the part you need
Allah said that that sounds pretty
Trumpy it actually you know you'll have
the whole left than ever virtually every
Democrat against the other okay you need
a thicker social insurance network you
need you need a real health care system
because what we have to deal with we
have to deal with the crisis and life
expect we have to care for each other
more the idea that we went through in
the whole second Obama term people who
didn't graduate from college living less
long than their parents which literally
did not happen in the great depression
and not only did nobody do anything but
nobody even noticed me this was found
out my pair of economists who happened
to look at some data as no one was
paying a lot of attention to this the
opioid epidemic erupted with no one in
Washington paying much attention to it I
mean we're going to need to build a
stronger a stronger sense of national
identity and but it's going to be a
different kind of national identity it's
not going to be Sarah Palin's America
but we have to have we're gonna have to
find some way of agreeing what it means
to be an American and what it means not
to be an American is the inherited
problem there that we're caught now
between Trump and sort of the Democrats
that love identity politics and either
one of those is giving us the answer to
that I mean where is the voice that's
where's the political voice that's
laying exactly what you just said look
we've been here before
you know that melting pot story that you
were told it wasn't true at the time it
was a myth we created later when the
United States entered World War one the
biggest minority in the country was our
one of the biggest with german-speaking
Americans and there was real doubt but
when the United States would be able to
fight Germany in the first world war
because the German Americans might be
disloyal and the country went on a ramp
having to ban German language and
newspapers at suppressed German language
schools it wasn't a melting pot it was a
harsh and rancorous process and the
United States had in the 1980 after math
of World War one I'm
grumps in American cities that were very
again you know by white Americans
against blacks that were deadlier than
the anti-semitic can programs that took
place under the Tsar those were facts of
our history and out of that we built but
in the years after World War Two and for
half a century after it's been a strong
sense of national identity we have to do
that state building and nation building
process again and some and it's going to
not look is going to look out partly
liberal partly conservative but it's
going to be a new politics for a new
century and and the idea that people are
going to that and if anyone is standing
around saying I don't know I think what
I prefer the problems of nineteen eighty
two so I can have this notions of 1982 I
mean say you just not help what would
you say to the people that would say and
this is a little bit more where I fall
on all this that the government is just
not the answer to any of these things
that I hear you on all of these problems
without question no doubt but that to me
at this point that everything you're
talking about is showing me the
government no longer functions and this
the federal government specifically no
longer functions in a way that it can
cope or deal with many of these things
we get then bad actors that want to
wreck the whole thing or we get these
mid-level management people that never
really do anything and that you could
look at virtually every member of
Congress that all the answers that
you're asking for I would argue have
almost nothing to do with the government
and that there's other ways now
especially because of the internet and
everything else there's other ways that
we can connect and build things right
now Elan musk is the guy that's getting
us into space Warren Buffett's working
on an alternate health care plan you
know like that there's just other ways
to do this and that those machines they
can't work anymore look something a lot
of the great social transformations have
in the American history is different
from that of other countries in this way
that oftentimes the way the countries
address part the most effective cultural
change in my lifetime was probably was
Mothers Against Drunk Driving
that changed Americans attitudes they
changed laws too I mean the government
state has a role III think that for
things like the gun debate I mean that I
think that is going to be ultimately
addressed if it is addressed not by
state action but
in action which is whatever the laws are
just if you if you have kids and you
care about them don't have a gun in the
house you know that just as Mothers
Against Drunk Driving changed the idea
that it was funny drunk driving was
funny to the idea that was not funny so
we have to change the idea that if
you're a responsible parent your arm to
a new better understanding that if
you're armed you're not a responsible
parent but a lot of conservatives won't
be happier won't say that that's right
that's right a lot won't be but it just
happens to be saying the facts don't
care what your feelings it's just a fact
I think Ben would argue with that fact
but you can do that some but we get
reminds me has a sensitive feelings yeah
but they're of course your the
government has to do this and it's true
that dollar for dollar and pound for
pound the American government has always
been less effective than other
governments but sometimes it's more
effective and sometimes it's less
effective there are things that the
government is going to have to do and
the government doesn't have to
administer the health care system I
would hope it wouldn't uh there's a role
for the profit motive and for
competition but the idea that we are
going to accept a country in which large
numbers of Americans are uncovered in or
outside the healthcare system and that
people literally die because they get
they can't afford dental care and their
teeth fester and the festering gets into
their body and it kills them that has to
change I mean that in part that the role
of the state is part of if we're going
to have a new ethic of nationhood with a
higher border and more mutual care yeah
of course government going to be part of
that stand and by the way not that only
the federal government because a lot of
the I mean the country is big I mean
running California's challenge enough so
since you don't say you're a
conservative specifically anymore I mean
what if people are listening and going I
get this it's a little bit of book
because there's a lot of big government
here there's I know you're saying you
would prefer the government not have to
do health insurance all that you're
you're sort of all over the place right
now which I think a lot of people are I
think that's the situation we're in
right now what do you call that now not
that and I only ask about labels because
although they're becoming increase
meaningless I think it helps people go
alright this is my starting point well I
don't have a label for it because I
think this is one of those moments in
American history where you have to do
something new you know for 25 years
after the Civil War Americans kept
arguing both about the Civil War and
about its financial consequences and
then they began to notice that in the
aftermath that they had these big cities
grow up that were intensely corruptly
governed and a new new movements came
along that said we have you know it's
not like the legacy of the civil wars is
resolved it's still not fully resolved
but in the meantime we have to figure
how do we get streetcars in New York how
do we get the water clean how do we make
sure look at the aldermen are on to
aren't I'll taking bribes and that new
political and at first they weren't they
just knew what the problems were and as
they worked on the problems they
developed labels to describe what they
were doing but first you start I think
one of the ways that um especially on
the right one looking one of the ways
that we go wrong is a new problem was
presented to us and instead of looking
at the problem studying it we reach for
volume of the Talmud and they say what
did Rabbi Russell Kirk say about this
3/4 of a century ago well he never
talked about it therefore we can't do
anything about it I feel good about this
I feel like you've presented a couple of
interesting ideas that thank you and
that I haven't quite talked about here
and you're coming at it from from
different angles is there anyone that's
doing this politically I mean who are
the people that you right now think are
making we're doing it right now
you know and and I think look there
there are a lot of things that come out
of the Trump era that I are actually
good their perverse gifts that he's
given us one of them is by lying all the
time he's helped us understand how
important it is that people tell the
truth when one of you know you're
concerned about what goes on in campus
you know that the phrase post truth
began as a compliment not a criticism it
began by by people who wanted to
overthrow totalitarian truth structures
and over the way to many multiple truths
and they discover that when you do that
in politics what you don't get the
opposite of truth isn't truth the
opposite of truth is lying
we've seen rising levels of civic
engagement and we I think are seeing
especially among the young a sense that
the political categories
inherited are obsolete yeah and that
they have to start looking at problems
anew and that they have to begin with
the problems and then develop the
solutions and then people will disagree
whether the new party system will come
from is you know as we really
contemplate how do we improve the health
outcomes of our fellow citizens how do
we deal with drugs how do we deal with
the declining life expectancy of those
who don't go to college they're going to
disagree and then they'll find
like-minded groups and they'll end up
inside the Republican and Democratic
Party so institutions will always be
there the content will change and along
the way we'll find new names yeah but
anyone politically I think I appreciate
the compliment and I think there are
some people that are trying to make some
sense these days but really I mean do
you with anyone politically I think it
will start at the state level you know I
think the mayor here in Los Angeles is
an example someone who's trying to
figure out how things work andrew Cuomo
in New York I'm in kind of a bully but
cares about why doesn't why is it cost
three times as much or whatever it is to
build a subway in New York as in London
and so I think this the regeneration of
the American political system has always
come from cities and states and I think
that will be even more true in the 21st
century I mean here in California what
you need you need a revival of political
competition mm-hmm one of the reasons
why I stay a registered Republican is
you know I look at California said this
is what happens when you get a one-party
state you get factional politics it
doesn't mitigate the problems of
ethnically driven politics that makes
them worse so we're gonna need we're
gonna need to party competition we're
gonna need new solutions that's what
that's what I try to do in my work is to
try to offer you know the possibility of
a more useful kind of politics yeah it's
interesting because I mean that's
exactly what I try to do with your show
and even last week I had Mike
Shellenberger on who's running as a
Democrat you know he he's more of an
old-school Democrat and he's into
nuclear power and all sorts of new ideas
and using technology to solve our
problems Ronnie against Gavin Newsom who
is who's the hero of the left and he
thinks sounds too left and then this
week I have you on to discuss your
frustrations with the the Conservatives
and all
so that's this is what we have to keep
doing at the end of the day that's all
we got right that's all as well as and
as long and we have to defend our
ability to do that and defend that both
against those who would use violence and
against those who would use corruption
to try to shut down proper discussions
perfect that's a perfect ending right
there thank you fo i sir spelled yeah my
pleasure I suspect we'll do this again
maybe we'll get banned in here and we'll
do that little fax over feelings things
that we get a couple other people in
here too to mix up some of the ideas for
more on David follow him on twitter at
david fromm and check out his book from
Bhakra see in the link right down below
[Music]
you